yeah
sure
away we'll be too low
[Music]
okay so we're stting it's a pleasure to
see this room so full I really see that
Co so it's it's really um I'm so happy
that I see that so you see here I have
to tell we have several sponsors this
time so British logical program is
helping us to fund student runs six
helps us with refreshments and lunches
and uh finally the school of computing
heing then kindly offered us to use this
space fre of charge and so it's it's a
it's also a huge support to have this
building all for us for two days so I
thank all the sponsors and I'll come
with more thanks as well in a second so
to start with the venues U so if this
where we are is called wolson lecture
theater so if you see wolson somewhere
on some Sciences here and the street uh
is exactly the room where you have all
your posters so again if you hear local
people in the New York say well have you
left your bed in the street so it's not
exactly in the street it's in that room
where we have our posters and um and
there we're going to have all our
coffees and lunches another place uh
another venue of the workshop will be
aex hotel where we're going to have
dinner today and you have all the
locations on the maps uh either in the
printed m that you got with your
registration pack or on the web page J
was TR to all the maps on the web page
as well and uh so but if you sure this
approach either me or Jonathan so
Jonathan will stand up and say hello
he's the second organizer this nothing
of this would happen without him because
I wouldn't agree to organize a cont
without him to start so um so that's my
thanks
to and to Sebastian Stein is the second
organizer question is here
now question oh but he was at the
registration desk so he's a PhD student
in computer vision here and um also lots
of thanks to him after Workshop program
committee also helped in different
stages and um I want to thank two vited
speakers for here to come today first
one is Jose Robin he's going to uh
actually tell us about machine learning
and automated reasoning and um J if you
can stand up and say hello to everyone
well um invited invited speakers uh in
in this Workshop play a very special
role because as you have noticed from
the program there are discussion
sessions organized around invited talks
and so um we basically going to focus on
two topics determined by our two invited
speakers so this is the person we're
going to interrogate today on several
you're welcome uh and the second uh
invited speaker is m hello so here
here's him so it's another very
important person we're going to have a
lot of discussion with him discussions
with him about his talk and also during
the special
discussion so uh actually I changed a
little bit the traditional Workshop CL
of the made workshop and the program
committee uh is skeptical about that I
know some some program skeptical about
my Innovations but normally in a reing
workshop we've had 5 minutes
presentation
and a lot of uh effort was going into
organizing poster sessions where all of
the discussions are taking place well um
it's completely uh my fault to change
this so this year we have 15 minutes
talks and 5 minutes for discussion for
every regular presentation and uh this
comes from my own experience I once came
workshop and felt that 5 minutes were
not enough for me to tell all I wanted
so I changed it this year um using my
authority that I'm I'm an organizer but
please could I ask you with this we we
increase time three times now to 15
minutes could I ask you not to Tres past
15 minutes and really leave 5 minutes
for discussion because it's really an
important part of the workshop to have
that discussion okay please don't go on
for 20 minutes because that will be four
times in fre and programing committee
will never forgive me um so then we
still have this traditional poster
session that reasoning Workshop has and
it's today at 43 te nevertheless I asked
everyone to hand their posters just now
so that during all the coffee breaks and
all during all the lunches we can still
see those posters and have those
discussions because it's all nice to
organize in one in the same
room and um and finally the special
discussion sessions that I noticed
arranged around the invited uh speaker
topics so um I also want to thank
session chairs I think we have
absolutely um fantastic set
chairs this time so two of the chairs
will be invited speakers and plus
several people are here to chair
different session so Ursula Martin from
Queen Mary London will help us with
today's discussion on machine learning
pleas me she has her own perspective on
this she's been working with
mathematical knowledge Discovery for for
a while now so hopefully she will
contribute to this
discussion Alexander B Minister will uh
Che talk to tomorrow we
have AG to cheer loic
[Music]
sessionid from University of Manchester
is right there she help us to do more
monaton projects so can I I I can't see
Ursula can I see no ursul is now busy so
alexand B who going to help with invited
talk to is right there so you can your
canc everyone knows you lelia is is
right there so um here's Ursula just on
the slide where we mention you very good
goodness I've been in this room before I
always find it so
scary be more scary if you're up at the
top so Anthony L from Oxford will chair
the model checking session he's there so
could you could you stand up so everyone
sees you but I really I really count on
session chairs for this Workshop to make
the discussion more interesting and uh
conceptually richer okay so that's why
I'm at the moment want you all to see
who they are Roy de is World expert in
Tau and cul so he's going to chare that
session thanks for for being to to do
this and p
n he'll join us for the constraints
andaction
session and uh that's I'm done with my
welcoming speech so I hope you enjoy the
workshop and uh please welcome and he so
in formal way AI over large formal
knowledge basis
oh oh hi um so it's a pleasure to be
here thanks a lot for inviting me I've
never been here before so I do not know
what the interaction mode is
so is the chair so so I guess you you
will no I I'm shairing your session will
share the discussion session so I'm I'm
here and I'll make sure order
is it's more question oriented or if you
just want me to talk for one hour well
it's up to you do you want us to ask
questions during the talk it's fine if
you inter I I have packed quite a lot of
things into it you can see the title
it's about one decade uh so I cannot
pack it in full detail in one hour so I
I guess it slightly also depends on on
you to really U um ask questions um
about your
interest um so let's get into it um so
the the structure of the talk
is I would like to give you some
motivation which is fairly
U uh kind of large scale uh fairly
ambitious and and people get usually
quite critical when they they hear these
fancy AI ideas they that that have
failed for a long time
go so so so after I I I give you all all
these fensive AI motivation I I'll
switch to examples of things which
actually work and you will see that that
there really are things I would I
wouldn't call Google AI fancy AI that
failed a long time ago Google failed no
I said I would not call Google fancy AI
yeah but but many people who who knew
about AI before Google came they they
they knew the AI winter Etc so I think
actually wasn't the AI winter debate in
Eden at some point the the one in which
M joh McCarthy I I interrupted you yeah
oh okay so so after some of this
introductions I'll show you basically
three three U ways in which know we we
use some Ai and machine learning methods
today uh to
to do automated reasoning and that's uh
most prominently premise selection if
you if you want to do reasoning over
large
formal mathematical
like there are also methods which really
improve automated F if you if you
have set of
problems uh and particular life problems
that there are always how how to improve
the very
profile
internally and the the third thing is
probably the most a I think that that's
kind of systems or meta systems which uh
in some ways uh inter the the say
inductive and deductive parts of of the
AI so so say say the machine
parts the
alter and the
about I might say some f stories and
some
challenges so so for for for the
motivation so since
2007 when Larry released a tool called
Slammer which helps uh is all people to
to prove uh the more efficient in in the
uh is
systems uh that there has been quite
of reasonable excitement about about the
possibility to use automated reasoning
methods to to assist interactive doing
and verification
so I I told
this last year and his opinion is
that this technology
today gives him about four times speed
up in comparison with the state before
we have this technology the the the
speed of intering thanks to these
Technologies at this point it's about
four
times uh that it was say in the year
2000 when we we didn't have this strong
automation tool so so that that's
certainly a very good motivation why
to U automated reasoning over large
formal knowledge basis but said my
motivation is more
ambitious and um the motivation is
basically the AI is today split into two
parts where there's this dtive AI like
the which used to be called AI in the'
70s and 60s but no longer is called
Ai and today what is called AI is Google
machine learning Etc so so these people
very much feel to be the the right a
today but they also are the right AI
because they they don't really any de
reasoning they they don't do what
mathematicians do they they don't
discover long chains of great reasoning
so so if you if you want to emulate a
mathematician or or a scientist I I I
think you have to do both these things
you really have to have access to a lot
of data and you have to have some
pattern matching and and data mining
capabilities to
to look at the data but you also have to
have the capabilities to really iner
various things from the
data and sometimes those things you are
very surprising so they might contct
your initial intuition about about the
data that happens in sence all the time
like quantum physics is very cont
inuitive or rela very inuitive but
thanks to the induction we we arve that
that some things things which we have to
accept
and so so uh to be able to do at least
mathematics and perhaps you actually
science
automatically uh we really should be
looking at least looking at that systems
which can do both these things and perh
combine these two kind of so so that's
my that's mytivation foring
this and the way how how to get to it um
well um so where can you do deduction uh
it's hard I might tell you later how how
hard it is uh if if you have a small
contradiction in your theory if if you
use today's automatic reasoning feing
that means like vampire e
Etc you will Sol everything one contion
is enough for you to solve everything so
uh and basically it seems to me that
there is just one good large uh object
of studies today and then that's the SL
release of formal you can say
matics
matics Still Know This Much
libraries uh which contain really a lot
of deep uh thinking or we say
mathematical thinking which is
noncontradictory
and uh which is totally understandable
to computers uh because it's exactly
because it's formally verified so
understand the computers so so you can
do very deep deduction on on that that's
what all these formal people do they
they you explain things to computers and
ensure that non contradictory but
because it is big and because it
contains a lot of human thinking
developed over the past centuries like
thetical theor like
you really have a lot of things in these
series these days uh you can also all
kind of inductive AI that you can do all
kind of data
mining that so so it seem to me that
it's a very good project for starting to
the meth which for combine
these
um so that that basically what happened
in in the past 10 years
the uh the visar library which is I
don't know 100,000 theorems of the isab
library which it depends on how how you
count 20,000 to I know 50,000 uh the fly
Library this light system by and steam
all all these things have
been in a non-contradictory
way made
accessible to tools like for
automated um so so so that it it to a
part translations from the Logics of
those systems to to the Logics of say
say vampire
Etc uh but today we can say that on some
basic level it's done and and we can
really
the
the um and once we have this kind of
corpora we can really get into
development all these AI so so we
can develop all these tools like
HTP and decision procedures Ian we can
obviously use everything which the
Google people develop on Machine
Tool all these kind of machine learning
tools and what we can do and they
typically cannot do so well we can also
build Combine systems so you can really
combine B deduction with machine
learning so so that that's
the interesting stuff that we can
do we can also test
performance and as the performance grows
it has grown in the past 10 years we can
extract more and more difficult problems
from from this cont and basically
continue this this Loop of developing
stronger and stronger AI on
this and as I said one of the things
really help that it's useful it's useful
at least for for the formalization for
for the
verification U but one another thing
which I should say have in my opinion
it's crucial for this not ending up in
in some wave or height in some next AI
hey wave is that it has to remain this
full so so it's not enough to to have
some cool
idea and published papers about it that
the the way to move forward is that
there has been lots of cool ideas
already and you really have to implement
your ideas and test them against what
already exist because otherwise you
might be inventing your terminology and
inventing some something which already
exists in a different color somewhere
some
so it's really important to proceed back
cautiously by building benchmarks on
which you very regly test very example
doesn't work
because uh so sometimes you get really
surprising results and this is like
should say it's high experiment science
is uh it's it's really data it's you you
you can do a lot of thinking but you
should also get a lot of information
from from the
data U and yeah I I'm hereby encouraging
you to if you if you are interested in
doing such things uh there is the CK
large Theory B competition which started
already in 200
eight and uh so if you if you think that
because the state of art is still
fairly low I would say you don't do any
fancy things uh you you can still
improve things I would say by simple
meths so if you think that you can
improve things that then definitely look
at the cast competition it's this year
it's like place it but you don't have to
go there it's part with the c conference
and enter your system you you will you
will get a cool t-shirt and if you went
last year at the during conference we
actually see serious money from
Google
9,000 PR
money
um so uh this was the motivation
B quickly about the cor that we have so
so as I already mentioned we we have
which is probably one of the largest
mathematical or oldest mathematical
libraries it's um it's kind of the
motivation is is to have this style
development of
mathematics only really formal and great
by humans and suff human
understandable uh and the first
translation is really 10 years ago in
March
2003 uh then at about the the same well
there's always been people working on on
the whole logic of it translation to to
FR logic I think one of the earliest
ones was Was John Harrison who I think
already in
1995 implemented that fairly useful
firster tactive in life which is called
the mative which is elimination per and
then since then there people like
Jo lar G just
who uh basically develop the these
translations further and
further and as I said
today since 2007 the
SL link is a link which takes your
Isel translates it to First sense it
also to
high to one one of these viers they they
if if they prove it then then you you
try to reconstruct the proof back in in
is and then very recently we
did we did a similar work
for light and for especially for for the
fly purpos by to Tom
H that's
a very newly developed
formalization which uh Tom hell is a
mathematician who
proved the cap conjecture the conjecture
about the optimal stacking of of balls
spheres and in
space and the proof requires quite a lot
of mathematics but it also requires of
computation uh
so the the verification of the
was difficult and was taking a lot of
time and it turns out that basically the
only way how to verify the proof is to
do it formally and light
and uh the fly formalization is today
about
14,000
theorems so so it's also sizable piece
piece of
mathematics do we know sort of the
percentage how much is done of that now
of the whole
flash yeah all of the mathematics is
done um that there are the computational
parts which need verification and that's
kind of challenging because it might
need quite a l of resources because you
really need to certify the computation
instead of just running it um so on on
his page uh he
has there are still some nonlinear
equations which need to be run I I I
believe the technology is basically
developed for for doing that
but uh they really need the
computational resources to to do it and
it hasn't been fully fully done yet so
so we cannot say at this point that the
comple conjecture holds that that's
still not toly formally
very but I I think all all the human
where was basically unless something
weird appears in those equations
which um
yeah one interesting thing is that on
top of these develop this interesting
kind of AI St so so so we we have all
these ATD calcul which partially are
developed because of other reasons for
example the solers are extremely useful
for for
verification there are instantiation
methods which
appeared for for different reasons but
again are useful for for these uh live
theories uh there is very def fun on on
E very it before the the SL the appeared
but by it's very kind of AI style um and
then it's so so in in in the meantime uh
he he really added he he has been adding
the AI features to e to uh to to make it
very suitable for for for the SL theor
so
so uh and and we currently do not
influence the the progress for example
in statistical machine learning but but
there is a lot of progress without us so
so
uh I I think that there's a Val of
methods which have been developed in the
last 15 20 years machine learning that
that we really just need
to import modify and twak for uh our
users
okay um so I do not see the time anywh
on this okay so so let me get uh to uh
to these um applications that we
do uh so as I said the biggest and most
established to today is premise
selection so so it's really the most
obious thing that you have to do once
you have translated the large library
for for like vampire
e uh so so especially back in
well R is years
so I hope you will not bash me too much
but the tool which is very very useful
for example for forar with it when it's
translated type
system when it's type system is
translated fast because it does all kind
of S soft um so Ty
reasoning uh so so so that's good I I I
could use it in iOS but at the same time
uh if if you gave pass a problem which
had signature 500 we reach something
like I don't know 500 symbols in a
signature that then just passing the
problem would probably take 5 minutes
because simply the data structures in
these G
optimized for for live series that was
nobody think like the the problem people
are solving was give you me a group and
show that if it has some property it has
another property so so you need I don't
know three three symbols then you don't
optimize the data structures for this uh
so so Lo loading large numbers of
EX making indexing structures for that
uh that that that really develop in in
the past 10
years uh and uh so for example giving
1,000 ex to cre in 2003 was basically
impossible so so we really have to have
external methods which select the the
right and give it to
the and
uh one way how to do it is is to really
use learning so so people are doing in
various heris ways like the first heris
develop for
ISS just pretty well if it's reasonably
tun this kind of symbol based chasing
you you take the conjecture and you are
looking at the ex which have the largest
overlap with the symbolic overlap is the
conjecture then then you get your first
generation of and then you are looking
at the next Generations of which have
the largest overall the first
generation so so that's one
characteristic which was later developed
uh
by which is called sign these days
slightly
different a similar idea but but you can
also really use machine learning so so
if you if you have your
database
of say 50,000 theorems and proofs in
your
library and then imagine somebody gives
you the next conjecture if it contains
the symbols which already a lot of
theorems have been proved about those
symbols so so one thing how how to do
that is to look at those theor which I
used to prove
uh uh things that are similar to your
current conjecture so so one way uh this
is really a machine learning you can
characterize the conjecture using some
features for example the symbols in the
conjecture it's it's like giving a
Google query where when you put keywords
so so your keywords are on symbols which
are conting the
conure and uh what's the answer was was
Google Hit List which which you which
you get well that that's the theorems
which which are most useful previously
for for proving
uh this kind of um feature
characterizations uh so so one
U this is obviously very close to what
are doing like I I already mentioned
Google you have a large sets of
documents you have large sets of
features of where it's in
the you you can you can readily take LS
of research which already was available
in linguistics so so the first thing I
did was was to take a toop by a listic
group in University
ofur Champagne by denro who who had a to
fing this L scale large scale learning
and just just using a fairly simple
machine learning method called
base you heard some
basic I I I do something like
70%
average or recall uh in the first uh 100
uh recommendations we even by this uh
simple simple Google so so so if you if
you if you pain on previous proves and
if you uh take the next theem and then
you know how it was proved in your
library uh and if you if you let the
machine Learning System the Google
advise you what would be the good uh
premises the good lemas and
definitions uh to prove this uh this new
conjecture that then if you take the
first 100 um then then 70% of of of the
ones which you need
but we be there that's what we call
telling so that that's fairly good um
obviously many people were looking to
like typically how how do you get a
funding proposal rejected so somebody
looks at it and tells you that
mathematics is undecidable and that you
have ging Etc well all of that is true
there are certainly random parts of
mathematics Etc but these result tell
you that in these mathematic
there's not so much random this but like
very simple machine learning algorithms
can give you a very very nice that some
do U and that leads to obviously to a
lot of um interesting issues like how
how do you characterize the the the what
what are the features which is it just
the symbols or some sh so whatever uh
what would what would be the labels you
would be using you can use the all all
the previous all the names of the
previous theorems in in your library but
you could also use the names of thetics
for example you Som
combine so so it's really open wide open
field for all kind of AI
methods uh here is um couple of slides
about this is about one year one year
old evaluation which we did on this mbtb
2078 Benchmark which is just
278 uh theorems translated from the M
library so so that it's it's not too big
because the M library is still quite big
so so that we can run all these CK
competitions the the organizer which is
Je s usually asks me to to produce a
small Benchmark so this is one
and uh the graph shows five systems so
so the best one the blue one
K methods that's my students called
danine called multi ranking conjug
rent so so it's basically some some kind
ofal based learning and you can see that
it has
um so if you uh ask for about I don't
know
30 uh 30 best Google
hits uh you you will have about 80% uh
coverage of of the premises which which
the uh formal proof really needed so so
so the
coverage is is
getting you can see this better than so
so snow is for example the n b the thing
which I was talking about on the
previous
slide U which is good but beaten by by
the teral
methods and then there are other you can
you can see the sign uh which is the
doed uh doed green line that's that's
the non learning heris method which
which has a very bad machine learning
based evaluation that the recall is
low but look
here uh so so so when you do machine
learning you you just do training at you
you you just have some train training
data and S testing
data and uh the these are the things
these are graphs that that you draw it
either fits with your with your examples
or it
doesn't well as I said our domain is
much cooler than just simple machine
learning so so once we get the premes we
can really feed them to uh to an
automated
F and the the automated f is the
ultimate truth teller it obviously has
some limitations but it's a much
stronger semantic check that then
they're just comparing two two sets of
premises the theion Lear will tell you
well if you if you recommended me
different premises then than the
premises which are needed for for the
pro which is in my library then you are
simply wrong well but we all know that
in mathematics we can do lots of
alternative proofs that that these are
direct graphs and you can do pro from
this but also from this
Etc so so the machine learning might not
be totally stupid it might you're
commending to some some different
proof
uh it might be even more clever than the
human the proof suggested by the machine
learning might be simpler the suggested
by
the by the
LI so so the thing to do is to really
feed these premises to alate the the and
then you see these
graphs where the good machine learning
is still good uh the KN base learning is
also looks but you can see that the red
line which is the sign meth the sign
which doesn't do any learning is also
comparatively very good um so from the
previous slide where there it was the
the second worst you would expect that
there ATP performance will be bad but
not the case
and the reason for that is that
sign kind of suggests who
are quite different from from the proofs
which are written by the mathematicians
and the formal libraries
so that's one very interesting issu SL
like you uh this
um alternative
GRS and how how to handle them uh in
your machine Line
application well
one when you see two different methods
that that that car both good but but
very orable one one field of machine
learning which is quite reputable is
this Ensemble Ensemble methods you just
by various methods combine different
rankers so so that's what we did in a
very basic way and indeed the the red
line here is a 50/50 combination of of
the best learning method of the carel
carel based learning method is a sign
ranker doesn't do any learning
and well you can see that that
it's um it's basically 10 10% better
than uh than the performance of the best
best learning method here so so the best
learning method gives you something like
726 Sol problems on this two
2000 data set the combination giv you
77 so so again a very very simple trick
for machine learning increas your
performance of by large
numbers and another thing which we
tried not not to learn from from the
books which are exactly in the library
in the human library but to learn from
the BS which are replayed by the
automated
fers because the automated
fers typically um short of the proofs uh
so so so the way how automated gets to
the grof is is much more exha
while while while the human constructed
gr is kind of much more
directed and for example all kinds of
decision procedures or type mechanisms
may may may be used by by the human
based um
procedure which draws in a lot of
dependencies which when you do things
exhaustively uh are actually not
necessary and and so so so the ad system
if it is able to to replay uh the the
formal grp in the
library uh it's typically that for
example Hales the the number of of
theorems that are of accident that are
needed to prove the theorem and that
gives you a much better data set to
learn from so so if you learn from such
a data set it's as you can see here is
again about 10% better than than
learning from from the follow which are
so so these are kind of data improving
steps which are very useful
uh de uh de with this so so that that
was the mp2 2000 TR which is which has
been used for about 2 to three years
something C
Etc uh here are some latest data on the
Fly Speer so so we really pushed U
all all these
evaluations uh fairly High there we
tried more than 600 uh combinations of
different feature
characterizations uh different
preprocessing of the data different
learning methods uh different
atps and uh and then November I four
months ago we got uh 39% of of the
14,000
five we we can prove totally
automatically so so you don't have to do
anything if if you are if you have
proved your 5,000 theorems in in in the
in in the FP development so so the F
development grows from from 0 to 14,000
so once you have Pro your
4,000 uh and you are trying to prove the
4,001 if if you learn from from the
previous proofs you you have a 39%
chance of doing the next one fully
automatically without any anywh
basically and then very recently we just
by very simple machine
learning it for
the so
actually so so these data are using 14
combination of 14 different uh methods
but if we if we go to I don't know
50 then then we we can do 50% of of
the um
uh one interesting aspect I already
talked about uh is that mathematicians
are are good but not always so good so
so very often you find simpler theorems
and sometimes the theorems
are really much simpler and I I do not
have the internet connection but so so
so here's here's a piece of whole light
code written by John Harrison who is
really one of the best of for
formalization
people and he was trying to prove that
that the face of a polyhedron is also a
polyhedron I cannot it this oh I can
okay so so this the is written in whole
light it's not very so logic if you look
at it this for S say that is a real to
to n to to which is a predicate on on
carian F
numbers space
if you if you have if if you assume that
this is a polyhedron and C is a face of
it
[Music]
then is also
a oh so so that's a simple theorem which
took him quite involved reasoning it's
about 20 line uh technical proof which
really goes
into it kind of uses he heavy weapons he
he expands
uh expens all kinds of definition he he
uses uh
the definition of pH this face of polyad
explicit for example that that really
uses the kind of computational
definition of pH Etc so he expands the
definitions and that he does the
reasoning while get
back while we two by the
this
selection last year is much much simpler
so so we just found uh for for previous
theorems um for for quite simple facts
which were already proved about faces
and a fine Hall and um convexity of
polyhedrons and intersections of
polyhedrons which which give you the the
proof of the but basically in one line
you you could prove it matter
so uh that that's just just one example
of how these
things uh sometimes
produce better CRM than
the
um oh so so for for the F just to give
you a view of what we do when we when we
develop this thing um that that's that's
the whole Hammer like you might know the
SL Hammer so for Holy did the whole
Hammer but ho the hammer sounded better
so so this is the architecture of of a
service which now serves the fly spe and
all light for formalizes so so it takes
a query it look
here obviously type checks it and it
creates all possible feature
characterizations it computes it runs
the various machine learning algorithms
give give the advice and again many of
them the advice is given the different
different number of
premises if if some of them succeeds we
we expectra we the proof construction we
exct the ex which are use for the and
then again in par run various proof
construction mechanisms in the
inter um so so that's
highly paralyzed thing today it it runs
about 25
different complimentary methods
compliment combinations
these machine learning
alori so so that that's premise
selection
that's premise
selection uh now to
some uh things which are not so not so
much developed well while saying that
they are not so much developed might be
an over statement
so there are a couple of methods in
inside the today which you use you you
could say machine learning or some kind
of ai ai
guidance I think one of the best known
which appear it's toally independently
of of of the SL Theory work uh was the
hint guidance by both
ver and obviously for for and like the
way
before uh so so that basically in some
sense that that learns from previous
groups and and the way they use it is to
kind of train Au or Provine on easier
proves uh to make it uh able to to to
solve hards and the way how how it's
done is that they they basically extract
and to some extent
abstract uh the the necessary specs the
necessary intermediate LS which were uh
found and which were needed for for the
groups of easier things and they put
them into a hint list and the hint list
uh serves as a search
guidance uh so so when you then attack a
harder problem uh what you do
is that so so so you have this given CL
Loop in in Al the is and obviously you
the major Choice point there is which
CLA you you should choose and then the L
list tells you well if if you found if
if you infert something which matches or
which is matched by sub by by some some
of the hints which we know are good that
then you should prefer these cles in in
the given algorithms and uh so so this
has
been uh this
uh in some sense this has been uh with
some abstraction added to it used also
by theuns and in his pH on on he kind of
took it further because he he does the
extraction uh to to have much higher
level he kind kind of develops higher
old second hold patterns from from from
the L and and then during the search he
uh does matching over over these l so so
that's definitely some some kind of near
sniper method
which at least and E have already
Implement
U I must say I I I did some minimal
experiments with and I and can say much
about it but the is implemented
um never really worked for me too well
but what worked for me uh much better is
is a thing which he really has a
response to uh to to to these I think he
did it in
2006 when doing some experiments with
Larry pson he developed this conjecture
relative simple way in
he which which is also some s basically
just nearest sniper so so uh but when
you have these slides here you have for
example 200 500 um exms
in uh in your
problem and the way how
he uh kind of discards uh the things
which are not so relevant to toing the
conjecture is by having having a close
evaluation metric uh uh which says well
the closer in in in the symbol metric uh
the a is to the conjecture the better so
so that's can parameterize it and tun it
in many many ways and and you using this
very gold directed aristic uh the
performance of e can can can beated very
significantly then again it's just a so
so so I think he recently uh made it
even more complicated so for example in
Slammer as I said they have these
generations of AC which are more and
more distant from from the
conjecture so so you can kind of mirror
it on on on the in the close evaluation
metric so so you can uh look not not
just at the symbols which CH directly in
the conjecture but but also in the
symbols which are kind of in the ex
which are on the first layer and and
prefer them that's
that's again uh pretty
useful so so this is kind of symbolic
um say statistic like s method U and
much more semantic method which uh again
has been helping um quite a bit is the
semantic guidance which goes back really
I think John SL is very
so so that that's basically using models
and counter models to to to guide uh
guide
your uh given CLA and that's I think
it's not implemented in
in but but that's already a fairly
different AI if you if you even call it
AI but I think people wouldn't call
Evolution say I but for for for us to
kind of experiment with all these
methods and try to find out what work
better it's on the same level for
example
symol U yeah then we have all these
methods how how how to
steer the
cers uh we many of them can interact in
in really un foreseeable ways like for
for example e has so many parameters to
and the parameters have meta parameters
so so if if you count if you expand it
to you get to number like 1,000 so so
how how do you tune these things how how
do you how do you develop good uh good
combinations of parameters good
strategies for for these things U so so
so one one one thing I I did last
year basically out of desperation
because e was much worse than vampire of
my set of problems and I was theuring is
the Google money and I needed to improve
East performance in in one week by about
30% it just show shows you how how how
simple the thing how how how the simple
things still still help really a lot
today you don't really have to do any
any hard thinking the simplest thing
help you a lot so so so that this blind
strategy maker you you kind of have have
a metal
which which tries you can do it by
genetic algorithms I did it by local
search that there's a paramal system
which is usable for for the it local
search over of
parameters uh so so so so the thing
which this BL BL system
does is that it iteratively by the local
Sur improves uh strategies on on easy
solvable
problems uh trying to
decrease uh basically the number of
given Clause Loops in which you you you
solve these problems so so you could say
that it decreases the the time uh need
necessary for solving this problem but
counting the number of call scops is is
a better better me for for this uh so so
because the problems are easy and
solvable the iterative search is is kind
of fast suit give it one second it it
doesn't very and it different
combination uh well and then the did
local search is good enough to to to get
you into some local optim how event to
Global Optima but what should be your
Optima well there typically isn't one
best strategy for all your problems so
so so you really want to have diverse
strategies for for different kind
problems and the the thing which this
listed us on top of
thearch that it kind of coevolves the
classes of problems which have same
characterizations where where the
characterization is what kind of
strategies are good for for for problem
so so you use the strategies as a way to
characterize the problems and um you use
the problems to to to evolve the
strategies further and you you get some
kind of a loop in in which this kind of
cools and if if you run it for 30 hours
gives you a boost
of basically
um I think I ended up with
25% um how quickly should I be silent um
well um if you want to have 10 minute
questions sort of thing then it's
probably about now uh okay we started 10
minutes later so you had your 50 minutes
now so it's your decision if you don't
want to have questions now you can
continue for 10 minutes I think I can do
probably two three minutes and then we
okay well so so as I said a very simple
AI approach gives you relatively a lot
to that it it's just U no no hard
thinking U just run your R
your let itow things by
itself and I don't know how much SL we
still have but so far there always
part so so there are s metal systems
which can do this kind of self Evolution
this blister is one one of them the
other one is this malaria thing this
machine Le for automatic
reasoning and that that really
know co co co
evolves well it it kind of inter leads
the deduction the running of the ser and
getting the proofs and learning from the
proof because there there is a positive
feedback between that like the more
proofs you you get the better your
premise selection gets and the premise
selection gets the more the more Pro
problems you solve so that kind rful i i
r months on the still
producing new
Solutions this is the
picture the architecture and you you can
obvious do these things also on a lower
level so one one fairly prototypical
system
is which basically pushes this into a
fairly basic but fairly
efficient toall so so we we just learned
from every every CL br
and advice step obviously it's very
expensive because the machine learning
device costs us much more than the basic
in that we need to
but uh well the the the pro search
shortening which
go for for all the uh problems in The
Benchmark so
it's again very simple and fairly fairly
efficient so so some of the aw
learned uh it it's it's not really hard
at this point you you don't have to do
much to to improve
things
uh some some things need some kind of
cleverness in when uh you should touch
these
things or where you should tou these at
which point you should put some of these
it's
like sometimes you need to know what
what was the right to play
Things
uh yeah
definitely uh the the evaluation is a
very very important Point like if if you
if you do not evaluate as I said this is
this is an experimental science and you
you will end up writing dream stories uh
the evaluation is very very
important but one of the funny stories
is that it's really fragile also so at
some point Larry had had this first
sensation of Isel prology but but it was
consciously
un because it was more efficient if it
was
construction but then it gave it to me
and and and this machine learner this
this Malia learned on the unsound TRS
and it found the uness in basically
every problem and I prove proved all the
problems immediately uh so so in that
way I Sol all these but wasn't us
because the done from from theing and he
couldn't reconstruct the problems back
in level so so so it's really important
that you that the translation is kind of
carefully down that that you don't un at
least that you
um decent construction which can guide
these things there are some challenges
like I think this premise selection is
still a huge topic we as I showed for f
we just included in in March by 78% by
fairly simple
methods
um especially for whole is dis
transation um methods and for example
highing Etc that's all very useful
foration
people verification
people there are many things to do with
for example concept introduction L my
introduction conjecturing
Etc one one interesting problem is that
when you get an ATP proof it may be very
complicated you with my colleague from
Charles university has a fairly new new
theum in C GRS but he wasn't able to
publish it because it's it's too long
with a 50 50,000 steps in all my no
nobody understand
it
uh and I think one of the things which
we are get to is when we have this
strong advisor like Hammer system we
need use it really as a kind of semantic
player for this configuration of of lat
written texts of of
uh trying to par lat text
into and and then see using all these
tools whether we can make sense of itamp
reconstructs yeah so so here are some
acknowledgements there is the T autom
reasoning
group most of the on the holy Hammer
many ATP ITP
learn reason people
in and finally don't forget to submit
your cool system to C 2013 that's what
you should do if you are interested in
this everybody is welcome thank
you about four five minutes of questions
so how did you build or how did anybody
build a repository 100,000 theorems oh
hard
work um so so the these things um you
are asking how how these things fed
or someone just sit down and write these
out yeah by hand one every 5 minutes for
30 years
whatever uh so so these things are are
called interactive or proof
assistance uh that's that that there was
a project called QED about 20 years ago
where people really argued that this is
the way how how to make mathematics and
even science accessible to computers and
uh really were discussing how how to do
it in in a reasonable
way uh so today for example have
Wikipedia so so one may have to do it is
to kind of CRA Outsource these things to
to students
the way Tom Hales did it for for the
Capal conjecture is that from his not so
big us funding he he was ping a group of
very very good mathematicians in Han in
Vietnam and then they they were
formalizing the proof
of for him in h so so he has a it group
of
10es and H the M people they they have
basically just a few they
this uh but they they are really very
enthusiastic about it so they they just
each time they see a mathematician they
they asking why why don't you formalize
it proof
Etc it's it's kind of viral if if you
get into it you may even start to
like there is a
George Pro of the
5 which is initial step to to do the
classification of Finance simply goods
and he did
it I think it took him about seven seven
years of his life and that there were
many people who were helping him but but
today he he has two two books leading to
to a fairly
advanc fully formalized in C and that
that was a I I believe fun funded effort
by all kind of funding agency and so and
having duplicate feels never Oh by using
ATS for example uh by by using automated
VES if so so one one thing for for which
these AI methods are pretty good is
discovering that you are proving
something which has already been proved
so so so if you are proving something
like give give it to to your Google and
your Google tells you look here's a
theorem using which you you might be
able to Quick your current conjecture
very quickly well if it's just one CRM
from CRM follows then probably you you
shouldn't be stating your conjecture
because it's just a special Cas the
general so that that's one way you have
all kinds of
other yeah do these proofs in the
project um are they all constructive or
do you also allow Pro
contradiction uh so uh Co there is a
fanatical division in mathematics it's
like Protestants and Catholics so some
people are constructivist some people
are classical so so so there are three
wellknown system which are constructive
the the very wellknown system which is
constructed is co and that there is agda
and
new uh and that that there are systems
which are
classical is
classical light is classical and is
classical so so so it's kind of for for
some things you definitely want a
constructive system because you want to
do some kind programming in it progr
program instruction from from the pools
etc for for some like for example if you
have a classical mathematician who does
General topology he doesn't know
anything about constructivism so so he
it's both but has there been an instance
in your work where the human proof is a
proof by contradiction but once you
formalize it you can actually show it's
constructed oh not in my work but I I
could imagine that that you get such
things I I
I didn't really
uh well it's it's probably easier to to
search for classical tools than them for
constructive FS but I I can imagine that
if if you if you run things like I in or
one of these inis the then it could give
you a simple Pro than what some human
some and it would be constructive but
but nothing that you know of as an
example at the moment oh well but but I
think if if I Al so I live in N where we
have quite a few constructivist people
who think very strongly about we have
the brow semin day uh so so I I'm
totally convinced that if I ask one of
these people they will immediately give
you an example it's just
the if you want to I can check by yeah
maybe one last question before
lunch no lunch is
better then lunch and uh we'll come back
here if you need to St all the
presentations for the next please do it
during the lunch break and uh some
people didn't register before coming
because they were something we'll
continue registration now okay see you
in one
hour am myself
[Music]
surprises oh